in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Liz is
with us from China no less yeah I teach
at an international school in Tianjin ha
so made it made the trek but you're back
in the States for a little I got back
two weeks ago I'll be going back the end
of July okay very cool well welcome back
to the States and so is that a
missionary work or you're just teaching
English everyone kinda sorta I teach at
an international school that is most of
the teachers are believers oh and I
teach actually math and the students are
English speaking your English language
learners it's awesome yeah that's fun
good for you and your hairdo you're
debt-free scream fun I don't think we've
had any by travel all with your honor
just to do the debt-free scream however
we still haven't because you were here
for other reasons but anyway that's fun
so how much have you paid off it was
about sixty six thousand total it was 56
K in student loans private school I did
major in German double majored in math
because I was afraid I wouldn't be able
to get a job if I only had German as a
degree I got you which if I hadn't
majored in math I wouldn't have the
position I currently have was correct
yeah so how long it take you to pay up
to sixty six thousand mmm started on the
plan about seven years ago I cash flowed
a master's degree in there and also got
divorced so I've kind of broken out but
for the most better part of seven years
I finished in 2015 actually okay yep all
right very cool very good and when was
the bulk of the payoff I actually the
last five years before I went to China
was working at a school where I was
eligible for student loan forgiveness
and so I had almost 17,000 forgiven
after having worked at that school and I
just want to say not the best plan
because the last year I was there I
kinda didn't want to be there so if you
folks out there are banking on student
loan forgiveness to get out of debt I
really hope you love your jobs or have
the stick-to-itiveness to finish that
last year so that you can actually get
it yeah absolutely and so what was your
income to this seven year period of time
started about
45,000 now with what I'm in paid in
China I'm paid about 17,000 plus my
housing is covered so kind of took a pay
cut but it's more than enough to live on
but you're also living out your dream in
in the way you're doing this yeah that's
right very cool so what started you on
this Dave Ramsey path because you've got
a lot of stuff going on in this story
that would be my mom having gone through
the FPU class and having taken me to a
couple of classes with her I did do your
online version of the course and I think
the biggest challenge with that is you
don't have the face to face
accountability so while you're getting
the information by the last couple of
weeks that the class not everybody was
very participatory anymore so I
definitely think there's benefit to
having an in-person class and an
accountability partner in the case of me
my sister who was always willing to call
me a fruit loop when I was about to make
a stupid decision only and she's with
you today she is she will be doing her
death free scream the third hour ah very
cool yeah we got a family affair all
three out of a three siblings right yep
okay very cool so what was the hardest
part for you in particular as you're
getting out of debt honestly probably
saying no to the stuff that was
unnecessary and saying yes to the stuff
I didn't want to do or that was more
unpleasant I don't have a ton of
self-discipline so I needed things like
the envelope system and my sister to be
telling me when I was being stupid so
that I could change what I was doing
because sometimes you can't always talk
yourself into what you should do or out
of what you shouldn't do
yeah that's good good observation we're
all that way we all need someone around
us to Pat us on the shoulder when we're
more a little scared or kick us in the
butt when we're about to go crazy and be
a fruit loop yeah yep very cool Chris
Liz most the times when somebody is
doing their debt free scream they talk
about how their income has gone up yours
has gone down because of what you've
decided to do
what would you tell folks who I talked
to people on my show all the time that
say I've got to say $100,000 in debt but
I want to go be a missionary tomorrow a
what do I do
obviously you've had to make some
serious cuts and make some serious
decisions while your income was going
down to still hit your goal what are
some things that you tell folks it is
helpful to get another job to help pay
for it so you can get out of the pain
faster it goes back to the whole doing
what you don't want to do so that you
can get to do what you do want to do
yeah
another part of it is gotta know how to
do the budget it really helps to do
envelopes with cash that was probably
the biggest thing that helped me
transition to living in China was having
the envelopes which by the way don't fit
Chinese currency in the little holder so
I had to take them out of the holder but
using the envelopes and literally going
to the ATM getting my money for the
month giving it into the envelopes and
being in the habit of only carrying
envelopes I needed to use while I was
out sometimes that was uncomfortable
because the other aspect of living in
China is they have it today they might
not have it tomorrow they have it
tomorrow they might not have for three
weeks but at the same time that cash
made it possible to not feel trapped
into decisions it meant that I walked
away from things I wanted but didn't
need and that was necessary yeah how do
you feel now I love it I'm also grateful
for your podcasts and that I can get
those in China oh very cool very cool
way to go proud of you
very very well done I'm sure your
brothers and sisters are proud of you as
well these are good times for you very
cool you are free you did it you did it
you did it you did it you did it a very
great loop if you previously formerly
known as oh my gosh our height Liz all
the way from China 66 thousand dollars
paid off since 15 euros in 2015 it took
her about seven years going through a
journey in life from
income a forty five thousand down to
seventeen thousand count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream son uh
all right I love it
several first their first time the first
time we've had the countdown in Chinese
that's awesome I was wonder she's gonna
do that now that's good very good
nice nice flavor to that good excellent
what a great job that's that's inspiring
stuff hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind